hey guys I'm back here with Kelly Carlin
and I wanted to talk about new year's
resolutions because the year is almost
up Kelly did you accomplish everything
that you were supposed to in 2014 now
you're just about to tie up the knot and
go hope I did it all that's it good year
I'm done you know I have to say that I
actually did this year yeah you did a
lot this year I wrote a book you wrote a
book I wrote a book that's like the most
i've ever done in a year likes the
biggest thing I've ever done so I feel
like at the end of this year that I'm
like yes I mean of course it sets me up
for total failure next year right so was
your goal or was your resolution at the
beginning of 2014 to make the book
happen was that it did you accomplish
what your actual resolution was I have
to say in 2013 I said to myself and I
didn't know how it was going to happen
because I didn't have a book deal at the
time but I knew that by the end of 2013
I was going to have something setup and
2014 was going to be the year of the
book for me so something happened I
don't know if I just I must have burned
enough candles or killed enough chickens
for that to happen i'm not at white sure
so is that the is that the thing that
instead of a resolution we think of it
as a resolution like you got to stop
doing something like start drinking or
stop doing drugs we know how about that
work what ya that the drinking whatever
works right like a given position that's
actually a great has anyone ever that
said I'm gonna stop drinking as of I'm
has that ever worked I don't I mating
for six weeks I think it all works for
six weeks yeah and after six weeks
you're like [ __ ] it I'm doing something
else right so for me 2013 n 2 2013 I was
in LA just for about a year and I was
like all right this is the year that I'm
gonna get this whole operation this
whole career thing new media thing
YouTube back to the next level and it
basically worked so sparkly word were
screwing the right shaman right yeah we
r co screwing wow that was that was odd
the back but I think that's gonna I'm
gonna double down am I allowed to do
that you like double down on my resident
cuz now it's like I feel like I did a
lot of good work this year and yeah it's
like I really like this is it this is
it yeah and I think like I mean I think
each year you kind of build on it you
know I mean obviously your health has to
be good and no major financial disasters
or something like that but yeah I mean I
think career wise it's it's kind of a
it's a pyramid thing you're building
your slowly getting to the top of this
thing and yeah go for it double down
bellow down yeah and see what happened
for sure yeah and then I guess we'll do
the adventure together yeah this far
right yeah absolutely i mean i'm i'm i
will double down with you in fact i'm
going to vegas this weekend so i will
double down on something at some point
are we being too self-absorbed to make
this sort of a career thing though just
as I said you know as you nodded then i
thought i'm making this to query
obviously I could do we can all do work
as people right make this you know you
know what sometimes though I've done so
much work on myself between therapy and
and all my spiritual practices and all
my [ __ ] retreat things I go on
sometimes my new years when she holds in
great reverence by the bars you can see
ya um and and I'm happy I've done all
this work on myself but sometimes I have
to remind myself just stopped working on
my you know just just this love myself
for Who I am and I don't have to be a
project I don't be like a do-it-yourself
fix it up project all the time yeah I
think people who are addicted to kind of
self-help and seeking and stuff it's
always like what new book can i buy to
help myself and sometimes it's like you
know what just love yourself I can't end
it any better than that can I just love
yourself and also comment down below
because that's really that's important
but love us in the comments that would
be nice